[Musik]
hey ich bin heute nicht als redakteur
hier sondern als fan interessiert mich
nämlich sehr für science fiction schau
das gerne kugel gerner star wars star
trek lesebücher darüber weiß mich
einfach anregt was mich begeistert weil
ich diese welten toll findet die so
viele leute erfinden und über viele
jahre und es wird gefühlt immer mehr und
jetzt ist was passiert worauf ich schon
eine ziemlich lange zeit gewartet habe
es ist ein buch erschienen die
geschichte der science fiction wo
eigentlich mal wirklich drin steht wann
es losging was da passiert ist wie das
ganze funktioniert wo ich auch lernen
warum ich das eigentlich cool finde und
was besonders tolles derjenige der es
geschrieben hat ist ein kollege von mir
mit mir hier im selben haus arbeitet
mandat aus unserem fällt das buch heißt
die geschichte ist gerade erschienen
aber auf 1000 seiten aufgeschrieben wie
das ganze funktioniert eben und ich habe
mir heute eingeladen um mit ihm genau
darüber mal zu sprechen aber nicht nur
weil das buch sondern über die science
fiction generell da bist du ja lieb war
ich würde gerne wissen was eigentlich
science fiction ist was er das buch
geschrieben die geschichte auf der sie
eigentlich schon wirklich eine weile
warten dass endlich mal drin steht und
erklärt da wäre es doch mal für alle und
ganz kurz ist ja nicht nur da was
sondern vielmehr was ist eigentlich ans
fiction von da wo ich stehe ist
eigentlich das komische das ist was
anderes gibt außer science fiction denn
literatur kunst filme comics alles das
was uns sozusagen begeistern kann an
kunst muss ja ein bisschen was mit
unserem leben zu tun haben und
tatsächlich ist es so diese ganzen
bücher die irgendwie sozialprobleme oder
innerlichkeit befindlichkeiten
verhandeln die haben mit meinem leben
nichts zu tun sondern wir leben in der
welt wo wir kriegen den ich für den
besten lebenden science fiction autor
erhalte mal gesagt hat wir unglaubliche
dinge rausgekriegt haben die von bei 100
jahren keine sau gewusst hat wie der
elektromagnetismus funktioniert was
schwerkraft ist und wir sind umgeben von
computern und alle möglichen kram und in
der kunst der literatur nichts vorkommen
zu lassen was das heißen kann was
irgendwie mit unserem wissen können und
dürfen zu tun hat das ist wie gesagt hat
perfekt liebling cars and my ob eck das
heißt auf armselige weise scheuklappen
bewährt und kurzsichtig ein kind wird in
die vergangenheit gespült und wird nie
erklärt wie das passiert ist genauso
science fiction bienen unglaublich
technischer physikalische biologische
roman von nancy kress oder krieg gegen
die
total auskennen mit dem zeug wie kann
das alles science fiction seien deswegen
habe ich 1000 seiten gebraucht weil in
der tat um nicht so eine müllhalde zu
machen wo ich einfach nur aufziehen der
kommen roboter vor oder kommen krone
vorne kommen zeitmaschinen vor habe ich
versucht mal zu beschreiben was hatten
das mit wissenschaft technik und unserem
leben zu tun wie ist das gemacht und
nicht was kommt da drin alles vor so und
die art wie es gemacht wird ist
tatsächlich das entscheidende in der
science fiction es ist nämlich nicht
einfach wissenschaft sondern es ist wie
wissenschaft was heißt das die
entstehung ist glaube ich zu dem
zeitpunkt wo das ding zwar noch nicht
seinen namen hat den krieg des erst in
den 20er jahren in 20 900 drauf kommen
weil das natürlich nicht immer weiter
zurückgeht dann auch sagt es ist sehr
sehr viel ist aber so die sommerstadt
mann scheint es ist ungefähr also im
späten 19
ich kann mir genau sagen da ist weil wir
haben alle eine mutter und die heißt
mary shelley hat in frankenstein
geschrieben und die hat ein vorwort zum
frankenstein geschrieben hat gesagt hier
drin ist kein märchen hier sind keine
ferien geschichten obwohl es was ist was
es nicht gibt er
und hier ist aber auch nicht gruseln
fleisch und gespenstern sondern es ist
etwas drittes und das ist einfach da hat
sie genau die kategorien die du in jedem
buchladen oder in der früher noch in der
bibliothek als ich klein war oder jetzt
vielleicht irgendwie bei saturn sehen
kannst nämlich die gespenstergeschichten
ist der horror da geht es um dein
fleisch und diese geschichten fantasy
ist halt der mann bleiben langen bart
wird schon ein zauberer sein so das ist
dann fantasy schwerter ja und dieses
dritte dass ich damit beschäftigt selbst
wiegt ist der preis auch so mächtigen
zauberer aber es hat irgendwie technik
na ja es hat nicht irgendwie technik das
wären wieder die requisiten sondern der
punkt ist alle drei handeln von zeug was
du nicht checken kannst also niemand
kennt den zombie und niemand kennen
roboter der denken kann
aber sie machen dich bereit dafür die
die geschichte anzuhören auf
verschiedene arten fantasy macht es in
dem es sich an was erinnert was kinder
glauben oder andere leute früher
geglaubt haben oder irgendwelche anderen
kulturkreisen glauben also sagt zauberer
weihnachtsmann hora macht es sinn teams
von sex oder grube spricht also von
deinem körper und science fiction macht
es in dem es tatsächlich von dingen
spricht aufgebaut sind wie ein
wissenschaftliches ding ich will ein
beispiel nennen damit klar ist jules
verne hat zu seiner zeit sachen
geschrieben über u boote über
propellerflugzeuge die absolut auf dem
boden barren der physik dies gab
und dann schreibt die welt über eine
mondrakete kanonenkugel
genau ja genau und schreibt ebenso
werden auch darüber wie man zum mond
kommt kanonenkugel weil gibt es müssen
wir halt mehr wumms dahinter packen und
ex die welt geht hin und sagt ein
professor karl hat einen stoff entdeckt
dass favorit und das hebt die
schwerkraft auf das ist keine
wissenschaft es ist aber wie
wissenschaft weil in der wissenschaft
haben wir rausgekriegt seit 300 jahren
bestimmte stoffe haben eigenschaften in
metall kann man kritisieren und so und
dann sagte er ja dann fing ich einen
dazu der die eigenschaft hat die
schwerkraft aufzuheben das heißt science
fiction spielt mit sachen die man wissen
und herausfinden kann und deswegen sind
sozusagen in science fiction auch immer
so erklärt teile drin also du hast in
jedem star wars film irgend jemand der
sagt du musst die macht so und so
gebrauchen oder das traumschiff ist aus
dem und dem grund kaputt oder müssen
jetzt den hyperraum oder irgendwas
selbst sachen die sehr weit von der
wirklichen wissenschaft entfernt sind
wie star wars
wir haben diesen film aber wieso kriegen
als würden sie bestimmt genauso also das
beginnt jetzt hector bremer bei star
trek zum beispiel funktioniert so und
ist interessanter ist für mich nicht
dass damit die menschen an wissenschaft
und technik herangeführt werden weil das
müssen wir sowieso weil sie den verkehr
stoffen arbeitsmarkt oder so sondern
umgekehrt dass die wissenschaft und
technik treibenden leute dadurch
wenigstens einen kleinen kontakt
behalten zu kultur zu fantasie zu
möglichkeiten und nicht nur wirklichkeit
was man zum beispiel daran ablesen kann
es gibt hier habe ich den mitgebracht
die zeitschriften nature ja die
zeitschrift nature ist so das blatt was
alle leute die wissenschaftsjournalismus
treiben oder wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sind checken können für
wenn sie eine grundausbildung haben mit
ein paar sachen die man so bis ende
gymnasium braucht und dann was studieren
was wissenschaftliches und sie werden
mediziner oder physiker oder was ganz
anderes dann kriegen sie nachrichten aus
allen anderen feldern und diese
zeitschrift hat jede ausgabe hinten
etwas das heißt futures und das science
fiction geschichte das heißt gott sei
dank gibt es die science fiction
sonst würden die naturwissenschaftler
und naturwissenschaftlerinnen gar nicht
mehr teil unserer kultur sein und gar
nicht wissen was die leute auf gehalt
was die leute entsetzt was die leute
irgendwie sonst so beschäftigt und es
gibt regen austausch ich meinen du hast
aber ist die klage in dem vorspann zu
diesem steve jobs film der sagt alle
werden computer haben es waren science
fiction autor in jedem haus wird so ein
ding stehen ibm hat noch mal zu einer
bestimmten zeit gesagt ach lohnt sich
nicht diese entwicklung es gibt ein
markt für 30 computer auf der welt oder
so der science fiction trottel hat recht
gehabt das heißt es braucht diese
kreativität oder diesen diesem ausblick
eine welt hinein zu schreiben die man
sich so nicht vorstellen können wir auch
nicht die gesetze gelten müssen die hier
gelten weil sie was wir uns frei setzen
und befriedigen oder anregen was eben
das normale in anführungszeichen nicht
gut finden kann neue perspektiven finden
kann zum beispiel eine angst finden
überwacht zu werden an die man gar nicht
gedacht hat bevor irgendjemand so ein
buch geschrieben hat so und die
techniken mit denen du so eine welt
baust sind bei filmen natürlich ganz
andere
da hast du heute computer generated
imaging und kannst die welt einfach
zeigen und viele science fiction
autorinnen und autoren hatten immer
angst vorm kino weil sie denken hey
dieses was ich vorhin beschrieben habe
dieses konstruierte an der welt und dass
es darum geht deinen verstand zu
aktivieren wird nicht passieren wenn die
leute nur was sehen
aber da wird unterschätzt wie schnell
wir informationen prozessieren die
konnten sich das teilweise nicht
vorstellen als der jace gegen metropolis
war als halle in essen gegen star wars
war dass man im kino sitzen kann
europol ist könnt ihr ganz kurz sagen
1997 genau eine stadt mit einer ober und
unterschicht sozusagen der erste echte
science fiction film na ja vorher schon
die franzosen somit ein paar effekten
weil du kannst als sehr schnell wenn du
diese technik ist mit der den film
machst du stellst du fest wenn das noch
so paar bilder nacheinander sind zum
beispiel ganz zeitlupe zeitraffer du
kannst ein pferd verschwinden lassen
indem ist einfach dann weiter films und
weg trägst und so und das gibt ja
sozusagen auf der ebene der effekte eine
möglichkeit eine welt aus effekten
zusammenzusetzen und diese schreiber
sind es halt gewohnt eine welt wie ein
argument zu bauen und deswegen denken
sie das geht zu schnell und das kriegt
niemand mit aber wenn du heute
diskussionen im netz verfolgt über
irgendeinen film stellst du fest die
leute nehmen das alles auf die leute
gehen das erste mal irgendein marvel
film und seen 7000 details die ein
filmkritiker der so ein anderes tempo
gewohnt ist überhaupt nicht mitkriegt
das heißt du sagst im prinzip ob das am
ende geschrieben ist oder ob es gefilmt
ist das nahezu dieselben möglichkeiten
wie andere möglichkeiten
du hast ganz spezifische andere
möglichkeiten du kannst mit dem film was
machen das kannst du nicht machen mit
dem text aber das gilt oder anders herum
geht der film macht es nicht kaputt oder
schränke zu serie was genau ist du musst
einfach nur mit diesen gesetzen spielen
also wenn du wie expands nimmst diese
netflix serie
da kannst du halt aus dem wissen über
die keplerschen himmelsmechanik gesetze
soll geile raumschlachten machen die
eine ganz andere genetische wirkung
haben als sozusagen naive früher science
fiction filme in denen halt einen
laserstrahl von irgendwo nach irgendwo
geht während du da plötzlich anfangen
kannst weil die computer das können
heute
die filme zum möglich machen diese
relativen bewegungen auch mit rein zu
rechnen und dann hast du irgendwie ganz
andere art von kollateralschaden
und das ist ein realistisches bild davon
wie heute sachen kaputt gemacht werden
realistisch noch mal realistisch
deswegen weil die gesetze des reagieren
benutzt werden können was anderes zu
erzählen was dir dann erst klar macht
was die gesetze sind als sozusagen das
ja eigentlich der echte zugang mit ist
jemand kaum verstehen kann ohne den zug
gegen diese person dann auch oft dazu
hat weil diese ist sozusagen das das
objektive so gibt es ja in dem sinne
sowieso miteinander ist hat die
bedeutung weist die zum beispiel für
dich hat und weil du bestimmte
erlebnisse dann hast wenn du bestimmt
die geschichte die ist die dich dann
weiter bringen oder festlicher erinnere
auch an den also kurz danach rwe-chef
die fünf die dadurch ist auch essen oder
auch das ist erstmal das italienische
technik überhaupt verstanden weil ich
genau schluss dass der tod ist
offensichtlich ja dort aber nicht
aufgeschrieben wird sondern für dich
sich aber trotzdem erschließt und dann
fragst ja woher weiß ich das denn
eigentlich weiß science fiction handelt
von einem gap von einer lücke zwischen
der wirklichkeit und dem was alles
möglich wäre nach allem was wir wissen
oder uns vorstellen können geht es oft
um solche fragen ist es wahr ist es
wirklich wahr was heißt es wenn das wahr
ist kontakt zum beispiel endet damit die
jodie foster war so und so viele stunden
irgendwo anders bei außerirdischen auf
der wega und hat mit ihm geredet fällt
euch dieses zeit portal fällt unten
wieder raus und dann sagt sie ich habe
ihre sachen erlebt ich muss euch was
erzählen das ändert die ganze welt das
ändert alles
und de facto ist es dann so nee du warst
doch nur zwei sekunden da weg du warst
du bist ja leider durchgefallen wäre es
doch gefilmt von außen und dann bist du
als zuschauer war so was stimmt denn
jetzt hat sie das geträumt hat die
einander waffe was ist da passiert und
dann hast du am schluss und das ist der
science fiction dreh der james wurzeln
in die kamera in die hand und die ist
kaputt die hat nicht gefilmt weil
offenbar die außerirdischen das nicht
wollen oder einen technik haben das
nicht geht
aber du siehst hey soundsoviel stunden
sind gefilmt worden das heißt sie war
tatsächlich weg und es irgendwas mit der
zeit passiert
das heißt science fiction spricht aus
dass es einen abstand gibt zwischen
wirklich möglich was wir wissen können
was wir nicht wissen können aber das
faszinierende ist wir können über das
reden was wir nicht wissen können indem
wir uns vorstellen wie es sein könnte
dann kannst du einmal noch so eine kurze
übersicht geben jetzt haben wir auch
schon gesagt wo es anfängt du hast mich
schon genannt und das ist mir heute in
2010 da ist ganz viel passiert und diese
chance
hat sich ja auch verändert es gab
bestimmte wählen einfach werden wie
rasend auf gesprochen aber es gibt dann
auch der für einen bestimmten zyklus
oder welle auch stand danach gab es aber
andere kannst du einmal ganz kurz sagen
was da was dann passiert ist zwei sachen
haben sich fundamental die ganze zeit
verändert das sind die mittel und die
zwecke zu denen man die mittel einsetzt
die mittel haben sich verändert weil es
ging los mit dem zweck den hat junge
girls beck der das ding benannt hat also
scheiß science fiction weil es seit dem
so heißt es war ein typ der
zeitschriften rausgebracht hat indem sie
zeigt stand und dessen idee war diese
ganze kultur hat uns nicht vorbereitet
auf was jetzt passiert haben uns nicht
auf den ersten weltkrieg vorbereitet wir
brauchen leute die informiert sind das
heißt das war tatsächlich erzieherisch
gedacht im sinne von informationen dann
kam die zweite welle mit jean gabriel
der gesagt hatte sind aber schlecht
geschriebene geschichten weil es sind
immer nur so textbuch aufgaben wie
mathebuch ich will aber was mit menschen
haben und hat den leuten das beigebracht
dann wurde klar in den 60ern wir sind
jetzt im 40er und 50er und 60ern wurde
plötzlich klar was heißt geschichten von
menschen das sind nur bestimmte menschen
nämlich jungs wie ihr amerikanische
weiße typen mit familie die irgendeinen
naturwissenschaftlichen fach studiert
haben da gibt es noch eine menge andere
leute gibt es leute die biologie
studiert haben gibt es leute die
soziologie studiert haben da gibt es
schwarze da gibt es frauen da gibt es
leute mit ganz anderen familien
hintergründen oder ohne familien da gibt
es eine der wenigen schwarzen da gibt es
dann als eine frau die schreiben von
anderen sachen und sie schreiben auch
auf eine andere art dann kommt nämlich
irgendwie rein die moderne hat noch
andere literarische techniken als
irgendwie sich durch leute wie ken welt
vorstellen konnten da gibt es aber
inzwischen techniken sind wir den 60er
70er 80er ist ein bisschen eine brache
weil plötzlich diese medien science
fiction so nach vorne kommen durch star
wars durch star trek auf einmal ist
science fiction hauptsächlich vom
fernsehen und film regiert dann waren
die etwas ratlos wie sie dem jetzt
begegnen sollen weil sony wo hast du
nicht wenn du ein buch liest wie du hast
ja nur eins sitzt das erste mal oder
auch bei koubek in 2001 aber davon haben
sie sich erholt in dem sie gesagt haben
dann fangen wir noch mal vorne an und
reden darüber was technik ist und was
technik wird und dann kommt cyberpunk
den 80ern und das ist praktisch schon
die sache die dass die herkunft des
computers und des netzes begleitet
william gibson zimmer mit dem gröbsten
zum beispiel neue mainzer und solche
geschichten
bald danach dann das auch im kino das
hat immer ein bisschen gedauert bis im
kino dann ankamen wenn es sehr weit
vorne war vom kopf her das war dann
matrix und inzwischen haben wir wieder
so einen knall wie
in den 60ern passiert ist weltweit
nämlich wieder neue stimmen wieder
andere leute china ist dazu kommen sich
in lu qing wang chen leute die auch
politischen ganz anderen hintergrund
haben als wir und deswegen auch eine
ganz andere vorstellung davon haben was
zum beispiel das verhältnis von figuren
zu ihrer gesellschaft ist und so weiter
da kommt jetzt auch kino auf uns zu das
wird super super spannend ist super
interessant dietmar vielen dank für die
zeit die du dir genommen hast jetzt
gerne darüber zu sprechen ich bin habe
mich sehr gefreut
eine empfehlung noch was ist das beste
was du in letzter zeit gelesen hast was
ja ich würde die vom hocker gerissen hat
ich war total überrascht weil irgendwann
denkt man man kennt das feld so gut dass
man sogar weiß wo man gucken muss und wo
ich nicht gedacht dass ich was finde ist
im superhelden comic weil das ist jetzt
ein bisschen durch nachdem ventures ding
nachdem das fertig ist die x-men die ex
mann haben dieses jahr eine serie gehabt
die haben einen schlechten film gehabt
dieses jahr da phoenix empfand ich mir
ist aber die haben eine serie von zwölf
heften jonsson hedman der sich überlegt
hat ist es immer die geschichte diese
mutanten die sind anders sie können mehr
als wir die werden verfolgt weil sie
mehr können sie wollen uns doch nur
helfen und dann hast du den radikalen
flügel dass das magneto der will mit den
normalen menschen krieg führen und
servier der mit den menschen sich
einigen will und man geht hin dieses
ding ist weiß ich nicht wie viele
jahrzehnte alt inzwischen diese expo
geschichte es gibt zig filme es gibt
natürlich unendlich viele comics gibt
trickfilme und sagt hey beides hat nicht
geklappt ich habe eine neue idee und er
hat eine fucking neue idee und sie ist
neu und sie ist eine idee und diese
zwölf hefte sind sensationell
und das ding heißt house of wax und
power system und an weihnachten gibt's
das als buch und wer science fiction
kennenlernen will von der seite die sich
einen dreck darum kümmert was die filme
vorgeben wie das sein muss so eine
geschichte soll sich das besorgen
vielen dank
[Musik]